We'll remember this, as the
last day of the republic.
I always try to help out the law.
We don't really know anything
of the rest of the world.
It was my fault, I take
full responsibility.
So, let's have a conversation.
- What would you like to know?
Bill Weasley.
If it's the right filmmaker,
I'm willing to do anything.
I'll do two lines or I'll do
the lead or I'll do something
which isn't flattering.
Good filmmakers are the reason
that I'm an actor at all.
It's because I love good films.
So I think I'm also just
willing to throw myself
into whatever they need
me to be for their movie.
Caroline, you mustn't let
this business get inside you.
The film is a kind of
a gothic ghost story.
My character grew up very poor.
Always looked up to the upper classes,
wanted to be from the upper classes.
There must be some alternative.
It was a very long process
actually getting the accent.
I worked with a great dialect coach,
we kind of invented a new accent for him
because he was from the working class
and yet he aspires to
be from a higher class,
and yet he can't lose
the accent completely.
I'm concerned about his state of mind.
So we kind of invented that.
We also listened to Philip
Larkin reading his own poems.
-I work all day and get
half drunk at night.
- He grew up not wealthy and
yet when he read his poems,
the accent he had was very
posh and then something weird
happens when you realize
that somebody has changed
themselves in some way
through their accent.
Who do you think you're talking to?
All remaining systems will
bow to the First Order!
Hux is full on fascist,
English upper class,
rolls his R's sometime and it's very
aspirational and strong.
Hello Harry, Bill Weasley.
I thought I had done a
really good job at my accent
on "Harry Potter,"
until I turned up on set
and went Australian.
True enough, owe it all to a
werewolf, name of Greyback.
And I couldn't stop being
Australian for a whole day,
my first day in front of everybody.
So that was the worst thing in the world.
What you wanna do is forget
about it when you're doing it
and just be able to be the character.
It's not my fault, it's not my fault.
They never really loved me.
They always loved him more.
They were leaving me behind.
I don't know those boys.
I always try to help out the law.
It's funny, southern
American is definitely easier
than a more general American
or something from either coast.
The southern thing, I don't know I think
because of the way that the sentences work
and the up and down of the tonality of it,
you can hear it and you can grab on to it.
It's an accent you can grab onto.
South African or Welsh, like
they're the nightmare ones,
they're the ones that you
just like wake up sweating
about having to do someday.
We always win.
I mean, I didn't go to drama
school or anything like that
so it's my own little
system which has developed,
but yeah, a lot of
exercises in the mornings
then I tend to keep the
accent up during the day,
just so it settles into my mouth
and I'm not doing an accent
when we start doing a scene.
It's nothing like that, war shock.
Oftentimes I'll find a poem
that I think suits the character
and that will be my mantra that I go to
because it puts you in
a good state of mind
and it gets your mouth in shape
for what you're about to do.
So my only function was to be someone
she could use to escape.
I'll keep it up on set,
but then when they say, "cut"
on the last take of the day,
I go back to Irish and then I can go home
and talk to my friends and not
have them hate me. You know?
So I can try and be myself again.